hello everyone and welcome to this
Advanced python Fill cost by simply
learn in this fill course we will be
covering some Advanced python Concepts
that are important for developers in
this video we will be discussing about
iterators modules packages generators
list comprehensions followed by that we
will work on regular Expressions
serializations partial functions
closures decorators map filter and
reduce functions and towards the end we
will be working on a small Project based
on our learnings we have Anish with us
who has been working with the industry
for a very long time he will be helping
us to learn the in-depth Concepts in
Python and he will also explain us how
to code efficiently over to you Anish
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on Python Programming in this
video we will be covering the topic of
iterators now penetrator in Python is an
object that contains a countable number
of values or its larger object that
contains a countable number of
sub-objects an iterator is an object
that can be iterated upon and what that
means is we can Traverse from each value
and we can manipulate or perform certain
functions or operations and tasks using
each of the sub-objector values within
this larger collection called iterator
now
um when we're looking at it technically
an iterator is an object which
implements the iterator protocol in
Python which consists of the methods
iter and the method next so to begin
with let's look at a simple iterator
we're going to see the example of a list
where we are going to Traverse through
the objects of a list using the for Loop
so we have objects one two three four
and I'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here another example a of an iterable in
Python is the dictionary so let's say I
have a dictionary where I have two
values two key value pairs uh key X
which contains a value one and key Y
which corresponds to Value two now when
I'm going to do a for Loop through this
by default I will be traversing through
the keys X and Y as you can see over
here and of course the other types of a
triples in Python are like sets and
tuples as well all right now let's look
at um what this iterating protocol is in
Python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects it contain
sub objects and when we use the iter
function it creates an iterator out of
it so we can one by one we can Traverse
through each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've got
manipulated or Traverse through each of
the sub-objects we encounter the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or iterated upon so an ex as
an example I will create a list where I
will store the values some simple values
in teachers one two three four one three
four five okay I'm going to create an
iterator out of this where I will use
iter function and I'm going to say this
is let's say this is called my my header
okay and I'm going to use iter function
as I had mentioned and I'm going to pass
my list in this
now if you see what is my editor it
should say it should be a list iterator
at a particular memory location now
let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see now when I look at
the next it should be three then I
should get four and now I should get
five as I use the next uh successively
now since I've reached the last of my
objects in this collection now the next
time I use this next function I should
get a stop
um stop iteration exception that is
raised as you can see here so this is
the basic iteration protocol in Python
now you might have already gone through
the for Loop video and in that I have
spoken in quite a bit of detail as to
how a for Loop performs this um this
iterator protocol and how it creates an
iterative iterable object out of say a
list or a tuple and how we how it
internally performs the next function
and it um breaks out of the for Loop
once it encounters the stop iteration
exception so
um for Loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now let's do a basic
comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in Python so in generator we
use a function we use like we Define it
using the def keyword and we Define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function the generator
makes use of the yield keyword whereas
the python iterator does not in
generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any trouble like a list to
iterate upon we may use any number of
yield statements in generators and we do
not use yield statements in iterators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic pick of modules at
python now a module in Python to put it
simply is basically a python file that
has functions and classes written into
it and is saved with the dot py
extension to specify that it is indeed a
python file a Python program can use one
or more modules and modules can have one
or more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now my modular programming is the
process of breaking a large a large
event or task into smaller and more
manageable subtasks and we call these
subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger application there are several
advantages to modulizing code in a large
application and we will be going through
them right now first of all there is
Simplicity because instead of focusing
on a big big problem a big task we can
break down the problem into smaller
smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through modules because they are
designed to create these sort of
boundaries or clear demarcations between
different problem domains there is
usability reusability in the sense that
once we create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically Define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in Python that promote code
modularized modularization you might
have already come across a coordinate
intro into functions in this video we
will be going through modules and
another video we will also cover the
topic of packages to import a module we
use the import keyword and in this
example what I'm going to show you is a
simple function or a simple operation of
importing the OS module this is short
for operating system and as the name
suggests we can perform uh system tasks
through the functions and methods that
are part of this OS module so simply
executing the statement will import this
module onto our program for us to use
now if we wanted to see all the
functions that are present in a module
what we have to do is use the dir
function so if we print the dir OS
function it will print us basically a
directory of all the functions that are
present in the OS module as you can see
here that like all of these are
basically uh names to different
functions that are part of the OS module
finally moving on another function
commonly used with modules is the getcwd
function and what this does is it will
give us the current working uh directory
that we are working upon right now so if
I execute this it will tell me what is
the directory that I am currently
working upon right now as you can see
seed notebook dir stem if you wanted to
see all the files in a particular
directory what we can do is use the list
dir function followed by giving a path
by default if we do not enter a path
since inside the parenthesis it will
basically give us all the files in the
current working directory which in our
case is temps if I were to execute this
it gives basically gives me a list of
all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that I am
currently working upon now a basic step
is
um creating a python module the simplest
way to create a python module is
basically creating a python script with
whatever functions and tasks that we
want and methods that we want inside uh
whatever module and saving it with a DOT
py extension
um so in in my example what I'm going to
do is I have already created a script in
notepad and I've stored it with a DOT py
extension that contains these four
functions add subtract product and
Division I have basically copied I
basically use this code and I've stored
it in af.py script and I'm going to be
using this as my uh as as a test module
for this particular example now how do
we import a module now once that I have
created a script in my example it will
be called my Cal vector py and we've
stated stored it in our directory to
import the module all we have to do is
use the import statement so if I had to
import my calc all I have to do is say
import my underscore calc and now my
calc has been imported um so we can use
the import statement or if we want to
import something particular from my calc
we can do from my calc import now
whatever like for example if we wanted
the ad uh the add function we can
basically just say only add or if we
wanted add and subtract we can say add
and subtract for example so this is
basically by using from we can say that
we want something from something but
only parts of it we don't want
everything we can also use from my calc
import and we can say Asterix to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc right now so this is
another way of importing something from
a module now to access contents in a
module we have to use the dot operator
and I will show you how right now so
what I'm going to do is in my example
I'm going to import my calc as calc so
now what this since this is the original
folder or the original module but I'm
going to give it a shorthand name so
that I can easily use it in my code and
I don't have to type out my underscore
calc every time so now I'm going to
import this as calc so anytime I have to
refer to a particular method or function
inside the script or this module I will
just use this uh this placeholder this
variable name so now I have two
variables A and B and I'm storing 20 and
30 in them so my first func what I'm
going to do is basically four operations
I'm going to print the addition of A and
B then the subtraction multiplication
and the division of these two numbers
and each time to do this operation I am
going to use the add function that is
present in the my calc module so to do
that I have already imported my
character scalp all I'm going to do now
is invoke these functions using the dot
operator that we're already familiar
with so I'm going to say carrot.add and
then I'm going to pass these two
arguments or these two variables to say
that I want to add these two and
similarly I'm going to do it for
subtraction
um multiplication and division as you
can see these are the results of my
tasks now if I had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt uh
or Dunder methods that are already a
part of any uh python script by default
such as built-ins so if I execute this
just to show you what happens when I use
the dir function it will basically give
me all the functions that are part of
this python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh denoting magic methods or Dunder
methods and these are like inbuilt
methods as a part of the script and if
you see here add division prod and sub
these are the methods that we have
defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
more detail into what happens when we do
a module search
um let's let's actually look at what
happens so what happens is when for
example we execute the statement import
my calc as calc as we did over here so
the first the steps that actually take
place are the interpreter executes the
above statement and it searches for this
python script in a list of directories
assembled from these following sources
that you see here so it takes the
directory from which the input script
was run or the current directory if The
Interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now secondly it
will list all the directories contained
in the python path environment that you
set up uh that you can set up or you can
change later on as well and this format
for python path is OS dependent of
course but it should mimic the path
environment variable that we see in
Windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search paths that is accessible in the
python variable system.path and this is
basically obtained from a module named
sys so if I import it this is and I did
sys dot path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if I am doing uh
import my kayak or import OS it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that I am working on it's also
are going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as you
could say directories or paths in the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages now what
if we developed if a very large
application in Python that contains many
different modules and we have so many
different modules that have similar
names and functionalities and they're
all kept in like or dumped in the same
location that it becomes very difficult
to track these modules what if there was
a way to organize and access these in a
much simpler and more organized manner
well packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module namespace using dot
notation and this is the same dot
notation that we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules so
let's try to uh let's look at certain
examples to understand what we mean so I
have a directory called PKG this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod1.py and mod 2.py and what
we're going to store in mod 1 and mod
2.py are the follows so I'm going to
define a function called Foo and I'm
going to print this particular statement
mod1 and then I'm gonna basically say
Foo and then I'm going to say in class 4
I'm going to have an empty pass command
similarly I'm going to define a function
called bar in mod 2 dot py where I'm
going to print this statement so
basically mod1.py has a simple function
where I'm going to print this statement
and mod 2 dot py has a simple function
then I'm going to print this statement
um and I'm going to store them in mod 1
and mod 2. py respectively and these two
modules I'm going to store in the
directory tkg in my local folder now
I've already done this so we can already
get to working with this now if I wanted
to access these particular modules from
the PKG folder I can simply use the
import command and use the dot notation
so I can say PKG dot mod1 so this will
invert in this will import the mod 1
module from PKG folder Sim similarly I
can do the same thing for the mod 2
module from the PKG folder in the same
line so now that it's been imported just
simply execute this and this Imports
whatever we needed now if we wanted to
perform a function that was a part of
mod1.py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly I can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module by extending the dot notation to
it in the same way now another way that
I can invoke I can import a package is
by directly importing the package Itself
by using import pkz and not accessing
any of the specific modules within it
now let's see what happens when we do
this so just for this example what I'm
going to do is I'm going to restart the
kernel so that the PKG modules that were
already imported get cleaned away so we
see what happens when we execute this on
its own now if you see I haven't
imported this now let's see if I can
access my mod 1 and mod 2. now if you
see here it's throwing me an error and
this is because using simply using the
import command on a particular package
only Imports
um you could say the package namespace
but it does not actually import any of
the modules and files that were part of
this package so if I wanted mod 1 from
this package I would have to actually
say import pkz.mod1 directly and I
cannot simply say import PKG and python
will not import everything that is part
of a package on its own I have to
specify it myself specifically now I'm
going to create and I'm going to I mean
I'm going to show you another type of
importing from a package using the star
operator so I have this package PKG once
again now I'm going to store
um three I mean four different modules
within this package
mod11.py mod 222.py and I've already
done this you don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
I've already created these five files
and what I've done is within mod11.py
I've defined I've passed I've written
this print directory and print directory
basically will tell me all the functions
that exist in my current directory if
you see here there's this bias function
that was a part of mod 333 module now if
I change this and if I imported mod11
and if I did the same thing you will see
Foo has now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all
functions that are part of these
different modules where I'm importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
the statement is saying from pkz dot
mod11 so it's saying that okay look into
this directory or this package and find
this module and in this module import
everything that exists inside it up
until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages and python
the conclusion being that packages are
basically a an organized way of storing
many different modules that we might
have created in a very large application
and these modules can be accessed using
the familiar.net notation that we have
used in other examples such as methods
when we were working with classes and
objects in this video we will be taking
an introduction into the concept of
generators so python provides a
generator which is like a function where
we can create our own iterator in a
generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions so let's look at a simple
Generator First of all so out here I
have defined a generator called my
generator where I'm doing like the three
uh like three
functions or three tasks that I'm doing
uh first one is when I'm printing the
first item and I'm yielding a value 10
then I'm printing second item yielding
20 then I'm printing last item using 30.
so let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword every
time we use the next keyword we will
keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store the generator in
my gen
so now we have stored the iterator in
this function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first task is
performed or the first iteration is
performed where we get this the first
yield command is done all right let's
see what happens when we do next again
next gen
no
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20. let's do it further next so
let's do it once more since there is one
more task there's one more iterable
inside
you can see this now a very question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another
built-in exception
um that happens when we have like
reached the last object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator and a function is that when we
execute a function the moment we hit the
return statement in a function or any
execute a function like whatever
variables are stored inside are lost and
they are destroyed unless they were
defined as Global and the function is
completely done executing and we leave
the function completely whereas when it
comes to a generator when we hit the
yield function we don't actually
completely leave this function so the
first time the yield is found we get 10
but the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next hit Triple so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in Python so to understand a
what the difference between the yield
command and the return commanders let's
take the same function all right
and let's put it return over here
after this particular the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to my generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first year will be standard first
item 10 the next one is again it's going
to say second item and then 20 but now
if you notice there was a return I put
over here
so technically when I did the second
next it's not only yielded 20 but it's
also executed this return function or
this return statement so let's see what
happens if I do next again
as you see I have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than I did
before and that's because I have used
the return function and why I'm in
return statement and what that's done is
that um if we've completely left this
function so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example I'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for Loop or for a for
Loop so let's take this whatever over
here and I have defined a function
called get sequence up to X and what
this will do is basically it will keep
printing the printing numbers up until
whatever we have entered in place of X
over here so if I said say sequence is
equal to Let's uh
copy this all right and say I want um I
want sequentially I want every number up
until 10 well not including 10 of course
because python starts with 0 right
so let's do this and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if I
did this again
should give me one
two and I can keep going
until I will stop at the value 9. as you
can see here
so 8 9 now I should get the stop
iteration error because that we have
reached the end of our iteration so this
is a way of using generator functions
for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator is
um in the case of Fibonacci numbers so
let's use it let's see how we can
generate a Fibonacci series using
generator so I've defined the Fibonacci
function called Fibonacci where I'm
passing Max so max is basically the max
value that I want
um yeah like up until where I want the
sequence right so this is basically the
code which will give get return me the
subsequent values of my Fibonacci
sequence so let's um pass this to fib
and see I want all the Fibonacci numbers
until 10.
so once I will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero then when
we
do this again we get one then we do 0
plus 1 it should be one next number
should be one plus one which is two then
we should have two plus one three and
then three plus two five then three plus
five should be eight now eight plus five
is thirteen and since 13 is greater than
what we pass for our max value here now
when we try this we should get the stop
iteration error as you can see in this
video we will be learning about the
concept of list comprehension Now list
comprehension is it's a neat way of
creating a new list based on values that
are already there in an existing list so
you can think of it like creating a new
list using a much shorter and cleaner
syntax compared to what you might
traditionally be thinking so let's go
through some examples and through those
examples we will see how list
comprehension makes uh creating these
new this much simpler and much easier
for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list which will contain
fruits that contain the letter a in
their name so we already have a list of
fruits over here as you can see it has
Apple it has banana Cherry kiwi and
mango now we want to create a new list
which has only the fruits that have the
letter A inside them so Apple would be
one of them banana would be one of them
and mango will be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few extra lines but yeah
it does it does do what we want to do
now what if there was a way of doing the
same thing by just writing one simple
line of code and that is creating a list
over here as you can see now within this
list you have this line this is what we
call a list comprehension so as you can
see it says each fruit for each fruit in
fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a inside each fruit and what
the